we've got new fox news polls released
this morning and it shows coronavirus is
the number one issue for voters headed
into the 2020 election
more than half of them disapprove of how
the president has handled this pandemic
i'm joined right now by the white house
chief of staff mark meadows he has been
leading the administration through this
crisis and mark it's good to have you
this morning thanks very much for
joining us
first off what can you say to your
critics who say
the president has fallen short in his
response to the pandemic
well obviously any time that we get uh
faced with something that is new and
unusual
you actually have to to engage and so
this came from china
uh in the last four or five months we've
been having to figure out how to provide
personal protective equipment
ventilators
making sure that we have uh hospital
beds and
and i can tell you as we look forward
there are a number of things that we're
working on to make sure that we have the
therapeutics
uh even as recent as this morning
shipments going to florida and indiana
and other places
to make sure that uh some of the the the
treatments that are needed in these
critical areas
are actually happening and uh i i also
can tell you that it's a 24 7
around the the clock kind of of work i
was on the phone with
the president this morning as we were
working on some of the responses you'll
see some new initiatives coming out this
week
as the president is not only leading but
will
continue to to lead and step up in a
number of fronts
one of those that you mentioned just
earlier maria is is about our schools
how are we going to open our schools and
make sure that moms and dads
don't have to worry about the safety of
of our children that are going back to
schools and so there will be
over 70 billion dollars that this
president has already
authorized to work with congress to try
to make sure that we
not only keep the classroom safe but the
teachers safe and the students safe and
you'll see a very broad
five five to six points in terms of what
we will be doing in terms of making sure
that our schools are safe
that's really important obviously we are
going to have to live with this for a
little while before we get the
innovation
from our pharma sector and a vaccine
tell me what the president would like to
see
in another relief package mark where are
we in terms of the relief and the impact
on the economy
and people's livelihoods well there's uh
the
the discussions have just started over
the last week or so
we've been having a number of internal
discussions over the last couple of
months
but as we've started to engage with our
our
senate and house colleagues up on
capitol hill
those will start in earnest starting
tomorrow monday i know that
leader mcconnell and leader mccarthy
will be coming in to meet with the
president and steven mnuchin who's
leading it from our side
uh to actually start to fine-tune it so
i'd see there's there's three different
areas that we're going to make sure of
that we have enough money to to uh to
make sure that we expedite not only the
warp speed
as it relates to uh the uh
the the treatments that we have whether
it be therapeutics or vaccines
but we also want to make sure that we
keep people employed
when when you look at the economy and
where we need to go with it
uh we're we're not going to be shy about
uh making sure that we have protections
for
the american worker and those that
employ uh
individuals and so you're going to see
an additional thrust there
um you know it looks like that that new
package will be in the trillion dollar
range
as we've started to look at it whether
it's a payroll tax deduction whether
it's making sure that unemployment
benefits continue
without a disincentive to to return to
work
and then bluntly we're looking at a
number of areas to look at manufacturing
bringing
some of those critical manufacturing
jobs back from overseas
so that we're never put in a situation
where we have to depend on foreign
countries
to make sure that we can protect
americans
and the president has talked about the
crime across the country as well
is there something coming in terms of an
executive order on
returning law and order to this country
well he's already done a couple of
things but he's working very closely
with attorney general barr
i can tell you that this week what we're
we're looking at is not
only uh looking at what a lot of people
have called
the executive order on statues which he
did that but that's really
the statues are one thing but it's
really about keeping our community
safe and the president's committed to do
that some of the unrest that we saw even
in the last
month or so but particularly last night
and
in the week leading up to it in portland
it's just not acceptable when you look
at communities not being safe and
not upholding the rule of law so
attorney general barr
is weighing in on that with secretary
wolf and you'll see something uh
rolled out this week as we start to go
in and make sure that the communities
whether it's chicago
or portland or milwaukee
or or someplace across the heartland of
the country we need to make sure that
our communities are safe
mark let me let me turn to the russia
probe you did such an
excellent job when you were on the
oversight committee in terms of
zeroing in on the origins of the russia
probe we now know for sure
lindsey graham told us this about a
month ago actually
so our audience was aware that the fbi
knew that the dossier was just
made up garbage and the sub source told
the fbi agents that
and yet jim comey and andrew mccabe kept
on pushing forward
renewing warrants to spy on carter page
your reaction
to what we know now and when are we
going to hear from john durham will
there be indictments sir
well i think the american people expect
indictments i know i expect indictments
based on the evidence i've seen
lindsey graham did a good job in getting
that out we know that they
not only knew that there wasn't a case
but they continued to investigate and
spy
and yes i used the word spy on on trump
campaign officials and actually even
doing things
when this president was was sworn in and
after
that and doing it in an appropriate
manner you're going to see a couple of
other documents come out
in the coming days that will suggest
that not only was the campaign spied on
but the fbi did not act appropriately as
they were investigating
it's all starting to come unravel to
unravel and i tell you it's time that
people go to jail and people are
indicted
it's just unbelievable that for three
years this president was
investigated and investigated again
over something that wasn't even true and
the entire country was up in arms about
collusion
i mean you know i don't hear anything on
the other side of the aisle about this
wrongdoing
which is just stunning to me well it is
stunning and here's the interesting
thing is
it's not only that it wasn't true the
problem is they knew it wasn't true
and when you know something is not true
and you continue the investigation
that's collusion that's the kind of
thing that we must stop
and that's what we where we need to hold
people accountable
mark it's great to have you this morning
please come back soon thanks so much
thanks maria